[موسيقى]
النظره على وجوه هؤلاء الاطفال تعكس شده
الالم الذي يمرون فيه وقوه تحملهم وصبرهم
هذه ليست مشاهد لعقاب جماعي لتلاميذ في
احدى المدارس انها تدريبات لمقاتلين صغار
في الكونغ فو شاولين في الصين
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده من عالم
غريب
هنا وسط هذه الغابه البعيده في مقاطعه
خينان الصينيه ياتي هؤلاء الاطفال لدراسه
فن قتال كونغ فو شاولين هذا النوع من
الفنون القتاليه التي لطالما اعتقدنا انها
مجرد مشاهده تمثيليه في الافلام
السينمائيه الاطفال هنا بين عمر السادسه
والثامنه يلتحقون بهذه المعابد بطلب من
اوليائهم لتاهيلهم وتدريبهم ليصبحوا
مقاتلي شاولي محترفين وربانا ايضا في
المستقبل لدى الديانه البوذيه
الاطفال الصغار في هذه المشاهد اظهار
قدرات خارقه وحركات مذهله وقوه التحمل
كبيره بالنسبه لسنهم الصغيره خلال تدريبات
خاصيه وصعبه للغايه تمتد لسنوات هذا
المقاتل الصغير يدعى ايكي يبلغ من العمر 9
سنوات فقط لكنه تمكن من تعلم فن القتال
خلال فتره قصيره
هنا يظهر وهو يقف على راسه وهنا يقوم
بحركات بالاونيه صعبه وهو يصعب ذلك لحمايه
عائلته من اي خطر
ماذا نعرف عن الشاولين كونغ فو شاولين
ويسمى ايضا الوشوشودي هو واحد من اقدم
واكثر الاساليب القتاليه شهره في الصين
وما يميز شاولين انه يجمع بين فنون القتال
وفنون التامل في البوذيه ونشا ابانا القرن
الخامس عشر وشارك مقاتلون رهبان في حروب
عده بالاعتماد على هذه الفنون القتاليه
كما تنتشر معابد كثيره في الصين لتلقين
فنون الدفاع عن النفس وتحضير اجيال من
رهبان الشاولين
عشان
في هذا
الاطفال ليس الغايه الوحيده
ومن خلال هذه التدريبات القاسيه والمنتظمه
يتعلمون ايضا الالتزام الانضباط اضافه الى
مهارات التامل العميق وغيرها من التدريبات
التي تسقل شخصيه الطفل
[موسيقى]